why are you guys so obsessed with ranch
dressing why is it on everything heats
up does not need to be cheap
inbred by so-called ranch no American
has been able to tell me exactly what is
in ranch dressing is it from the ranch
and does it contain flavors that you
would assimilate with a ranch why does
all of your money look exactly the same
change it up a little add some color
little flair like a big joke to pull
people when their drunken to tipping
more than they should who came up with a
1 cent coin
why we got rid of them a million years
ago I don't know remember one sentence
to think lines
how much did a customer it couldn't cost
one cent you're losing money you guys
don't even like pennies they drop them
they're everywhere you gonna tell me why
is your cheese boring why is your cheese
orange seriously my mom stared at the
jeans my like oh wait it was like not I
don't understand looks and why is it in
a can and I tried cheese in a can it's
disgusting it has a cheese Nick and
Jesus long I can cream I get cheese no
why I drink so how do you be yet not a
car with a cup holder big enough for
your sizes that you serve in America are
actually illegal in Australia
Australians do not drink foster why do
you all think that we drink foster don't
believe the advertising people we don't
all drink Foster with odd bloody VB
maybe got Forex their Australian beers
why don't you just add sales tax to the
price tag why don't you just add the
scale tags to the price tag like
everybody else so fast in Australia we
have a goods and services tax and it's
all included
it says $10 it's $10 don't tell me that
it's 12:45 I don't want to know that I
want to know the real price
your non metric system whatever you do
not understand anyway you guys do not
convert to the metric system or make
math easier go metric so sweet 10
everything's turned zero is freezing cuz
that makes sense one meter is 100
centimeters one mile is like that many
feet just keep going keep go
what's with your gun laws neither
against it nor for it I just I guess I'm
just a little confused by it crazy easy
to buy a gun I went to the Midwest and I
went to Walmart and they just tell them
that was in Mississippi and my friend
bought an ak-47 on a whim that was weird
when that amendment was written no one
had weapons that could dispense like 200
bullets a second they were muskets it
took like 10 minutes to light what's
going on your gun laws they're nuts
baby's gonna have guns why do your
pharmacies sell beer next to the condoms
and the tampons there's be a lot of
pharmacies so beer why the hell not I
think it's fantastic I love this country